esta vez voy a multiplicar 78 por 65 y
vamos a escribirlo
setenta y
por 65
en parís
quiero decirles que esta vez no lo voy a
hacer de una manera tradicional
estaríamos de acuerdo de que hay muchas
formas de multiplicar esta vez lo quiero
hacer muy parecido como cuando hago
multiplicaciones en mi cabeza y también
quiero mostrar todas las partes del
proceso utilizando esta figura que tiene
áreas que está de este lado derecho así
que empecemos haciendo la multiplicación
empezaríamos haciendo 5 por 8 5 por 8 40
pero a diferencia de otros momentos en
los que pondríamos el cero y llegaríamos
acarreando o llevando los otros números
lo que yo voy a hacer es escribir el 40
completo 5 por 8 es 40 ahora voy a
multiplicar el 5 por 7 pero ojo hay que
ser cuidadosos este 7 que está aquí no
es cualquier 7 está en la posición de
las decenas así que es 70
5 x 7 me da 35 y 5 por 70 pues que es un
cero más me da 350 y ahora lo voy a
escribir aquí 350 ahora voy a
multiplicar el 6 por 8 pero otra vez
tenemos que ser cuidadosos este no es
cualquier 6 este está en la posición de
las decenas por lo que es 60 hay que
multiplicar 60 por 8 6 por 8 48 y si le
agregó un 0 pues es 480
muy bien ahora vamos con el que sigue
que es el 6 por 7 pero siguiendo la idea
este no es cualquier 6 ni este es
cualquier 7 en realidad estamos
multiplicando 60 por 70 esto es si los
números tienen un 0 como en el 60 y en
el 70
voy a agregar el número de ceros que
tengan en total o sea 26 x 7 42 y 20 me
da 4200 y lo voy a escribir
muy bien y ahora podemos sumar todos
como le haríamos normalmente en la
multiplicación entonces vamos con
cuidado en la posición de las unidades
sólo tengo ceros así que en las unidades
se mantiene el cero ahora vamos con las
decenas 4 y 5 9 y 8 17 y 0 17 así que
escribo el 7 y llevo 1 lo marcó aquí
seguimos con las centenas 13 es 44 son
ocho más dos son diez así que escribo el
cero y llevo uno que lo indicó aquí y
finalmente en los millares uno y cuatro
son cinco así que el producto de sesenta
y cinco por 78 dio como resultado cinco
mil setenta quiero insistir que esta
forma que hice la multiplicación
simplemente fui por partes
aquí tenemos cinco por ocho que es
cuarenta después tenemos cinco por
setenta que son los trescientos
cincuenta sesenta por ocho que son 480 y
sesenta por setenta que son cuatro mil
doscientos o sea multiplicar 65 por 78
es lo mismo que sumar la multiplicación
de cada una de sus partes
ahora veámoslo con mi figura que tengo
aquí a la derecha y me gustaría ir
mostrando cada una de las partes que
corresponden a las áreas de esta figura
entonces multiplicar 65 por 78
dibujando vamos a poner las dimensiones
en esta figura esto es que tal si de
aquí a acá yo tengo una distancia de 60
luego en esta parte tengo voy a ser
cuidadoso una distancia de 5 vamos a
decir que esta distancia en esta
distancia que está aquí es 70 y
finalmente esta distancia que está aquí
abajo
con este color esta distancia que está
aquí abajo
es de 8 o sea que multiplicar 65 por 78
sería equivalente a tener un rectángulo
que tiende de ancho 65 y de altura 78 y
yo calculará su área es decir 65 por 78
y si voy viendo cada uno de los pasos
que fui haciendo aquí por ejemplo 5 por
8 que es 40 es equivalente a pensar mira
este es 5
por 8 que esto es igual a 40 esta área
vale 40 después si yo observara cuando
multiplique 5 por 70 sería equivalente a
pensar esta área que tengo aquí si mira
esta que está aquí que 5 por 70 que
vamos escribirlo así 70 x 55 x 70 es lo
mismo y esto tiene un valor de 350
después 8 por 60 ó 60 por 8 es
exactamente el área que está aquí que 60
por 8 y esto es igual a 480 y finalmente
el 60 por el 70 que nos da 4200 es el
área que está aquí que es 70 por 60 es
igual a 4200
así que la operación que hice es el
equivalente a sumar las áreas de cada
una de estas partes mira aquí tenemos el
40 que es el que tenemos aquí del 5 por
8 el 350 que le vamos a sumar el 480 y
después el 4200 que es la parte más
grande todas ellas en conjunto suman 5
mil 70 unidades cuadradas